- [Narrator] This vacant
parcel of land in Austin, Texas
might not look like much,
but it offers a glimpse
into how a skewed property
tax system is worsening
the housing crisis in
America's biggest cities.
The lot has an annual property tax bill
of about $1.5 million per acre.
But just six blocks over,
this luxury apartment building
is taxed at nearly double that rate.
Cities all over the country are littered
with empty or sparsely built sites.
Some economists say they
share a common factor,
a tax system that
combines low taxes on land
with high taxes on buildings.
Here's a closer look at that system,
and the often overlooked role it plays
in the country's housing shortage.
To understand the tax system,
let's head back to 701 Trinity Street.
Located near the heart of downtown Austin,
the 0.2 acre parcel is
valued at over $13.7 million.
Yet for decades, the lot has
only been used for parking,
and the owners have paid
relatively little in taxes
because it doesn't contain any buildings.
Cielo Property Group owns
the vacant plot of land.
They did not respond to
a request for comment.
- So traditional property
taxes perversely disincentivize
the kind of land use that we
want to see in our cities.
When you're taxing
improvements, you're signaling
to the market that you
don't want improvements.
- [Narrator] Josephine Faass
is the Executive Director
of the Robert Schalkenbach Foundation,
a nonprofit research organization
that advocates for property tax reform.
- So they actually affect
the way that people use land,
or choose not to use
land, which is something
that might not initially
be, you know, obvious,
thinking about property taxes.
- [Narrator] When landowners
improve their property,
by adding a new room, for
instance, their taxes go up.
In some cases, these taxes can be as much
as seven times higher for
a developed piece of land
compared to an empty lot.
- The basic premise of
property taxes in America
is very simple, it's
basically the government
will try to figure out how much
is a piece of real estate worth,
and then based on that
value you'll be taxed.
The more valuable your real
estate is, the higher your tax.
- [Narrator] Presumably,
the owners of more
expensive buildings would be able
to afford more expensive
rates, but some economists say
the system has an unintended consequence.
- It makes it easy for
people to take up properties
and then just hold them
until the value increases,
sell at a profit, right?
So they'll buy low, sell high,
but without doing anything
in the interim, including
building housing.
- [Narrator] Over the last few years,
Texas home prices have skyrocketed.
In January, Austin's median
home price was $525,000,
according to the Austin Board of Realtors.
That's a 36% jump from January, 2020.
- So housing shortages has always existed
in cities like New York and San Francisco.
What's really changed
in the last couple years
is that you're seeing more of this issue
in places in the Sunbelt.
I think Austin's really the textbook case
of the booming Sunbelt
city that's now running
into all these housing shortage problems,
'cause it used to be an
affordable place and now
it's really one of the most
expensive places in the South.
- [Narrator] But despite
rising demand for housing,
developers struggle to
find sites to build on.
- Developers paradoxically
are having a hard time
finding land, but even those
lots where law does allow you
to build, often people
just don't wanna sell.
- [Narrator] Austin alone has
more than 17,500 vacant lots
zoned for residential use,
according to Altus Group,
a real estate analytics firm.
In Atlanta, Georgia,
there's more than 13,000,
and New York City has more than
77,000 lots that are vacant
or less than half the size
of what zoning allows.
That's a lot of untapped potential.
If the owners of all the
vacant lots in Austin
developed buildings to match
the current density of
the city, they could add
over 1 billion square feet of housing,
according to an Altus Group estimate
that's equivalent to about
384 Empire State buildings,
or over 800,000 additional
apartment units.
- So it's really adding to this issue
of affordable housing or
housing accessibility.
- [Narrator] One solution
proposed by lawmakers
comes in the form of a Land Value Tax.
This places a higher tax rate on land,
while reducing Taxes on buildings.
In theory, this system
would reduce the profit
that comes from owning a
vacant piece of property.
- So if your tax code is set
up that you can make money
by improving the land that
you've just been sitting on,
or selling it to somebody who will,
that's what's gonna happen.
- [Narrator] Research suggests
this type of taxing system
has increased building activity
in cities like Pittsburgh.
- A couple of studies have actually shown
that they had more construction
activity in Pittsburgh,
relative to other nearby
and similar cities
that didn't have this sort of tax system.
- [Narrator] Still, fairly
assessing the value of land
for taxation can be difficult.
Some economists say it's
simpler to assess improvements
based on their income producing ability.
There are also political hurdles
to implementing a new tax system.
- One of the big challenges
in America is that often,
under state law, cities
and counties can't decide
on their own tax system,
they basically have to defer to the state
- When it comes to building more housing,
some developers say a Land Value Tax
may only make a small difference.
Factors like restrictive zoning laws
and rising material costs also play a role
in delaying construction projects.
Despite the challenges, one city, Detroit,
may soon implement a Land Value Tax.
If approved, lawmakers
and housing advocates say
this could be a crucial test
case for the tax policy.
- Detroit would be the biggest city
in the history of America to
implement a Land Value Tax.
And it'd be a fascinating test case
on whether this actually
works in the 21st century,
and whether others will follow suit.
If it works out, it can
really change the way
Americans think about property taxes.
(pleasant music)